bonsoir denis robert dont vous venez
d'entendre l'interview en coulisses un
garçon soit je vieillis de kersauson et
qu'on ne présente plus eve angeli votre
voisine jarry cartonne top 50 qui est
alain chamfort qui est l'un de mes
chanteurs l'un des mélodistes préféré
voilà ça va claude très bien vous
enlevez pas votre montre là non pas
parce que votre père vous avez dit
interview quand on se donne on donne son
temps donc on enlève ça monte c'est un
très bon gré mal gré la faites moi
plaisir à mon papa voilà a réussi à
votre père donc justement la pièce que
vous commencez le 6 février au théâtre
de la porte saint-martin s'appelle
conversation avec mon père donc voilà de
herb gardner alors l'adaptation est
faite par jean claude grumberg mise en
scène de marcel bluwal voilà alors
l'auteur de conversation avec mon père
c'est herbe gartner qui est l'un des
trois ou quatre grands auteurs
dramatiques américain des 50 dernières
années
c'est lui qui a fait des clowns par
milliers qui a été jouée par yves
montand et que beaucoup de succès à
l'époque je ne suis pas rapoport qui
était joué par jacques dufilho et cette
pièce conversation avec mon père et je
permets de le signaler puisque c'est
important il est quand même aussi un des
grands scénaristes américains on lui
doit rôle draps jazz et la liste de
schindler oui l'histoire c'est
l'histoire d'un père et deux fils l'un
d'entre eux est joué par serge
hazanavicius vous vous êtes le patron
juif d'un bistrot aux new yorkais qui a
débarqué de dessin en 1936 sous le nom
de isaac goldberg et qui en fait se fait
appeler et dire hausse mais qui veut
s'intégrer dans la société américaine
mais qui reproche à son fils de perdre
ses racines quoi voilà c'est un peu
simple à dire de cette année deux thèmes
de la pièce parce que je pense que dans
toutes les grandes pièces il ya toujours
plusieurs thèmes qui sont abordés à bord
le thème de l'immigration
vu sous un angle très particulier où on
démontre la différence qu'il est entre
la première
ouais sur des maigret et puis les
laisseront des générations suivantes
et c'est en général la première
génération des vitesses qui est le cas
ce qui est mon cas dans dans dans la
pièce tous touchants rible changer de
non-échange d'architecturé chante de
nourriture échange de langage c'est
terrible c'est eux qui défriche l'été
tandis que la seconde génération ils
sont chez eux
lui il fait tout pour être américain
alors que ses enfants sont américains
dans une fabrique le deuxième thème qui
a demandé qui est intéressante donc ce
qui me fait plaisir
la pièce intéresse les les jeunes c'est
le problème des rapports entre un père
et un fils et dire que l'erreur commise
souvent par amour par les parents ses
deux de vouloir pousser leurs enfants
dans la direction qu'ils veulent eux
sans essayer plutôt de 2,2 de trouver ce
pour quoi ils sont doués et on le le
rôle que j'interprète est un échec
complet puisque je voulais que je veux
que mon fils soit 12 de l'un devient un
véritable america lors il devient
effectivement un véritable américain un
peu stabilisé suivre nos travailleurs
gagnant du pognon pu finalement le
m'aperçois que les mecs qui bossent
comme des damnés qui ne dorment que
quand ils prennent un taxi et qui
deviennent milliards verbes sont des
gens qui m'emmerde de l'autre je veux
faire aussi un vrai américain je veux en
faire un héros je l'envoie à la guerre
il était donc deux échecs c'est génial
les récentes de l'évêché ce qui est
génial
claude c'est qu'en vieillissant vous
avez vraiment de plus en plus la voix de
votre père et je vais appeler ou à
laisser un message sur mon répondeur et
j'entends à l'eau ces brasseurs et bien
sur le coup je me suis dit j'ai
l'impression d'être mort est au paradis
et d'entendre pierre brasseur c'est vrai
que chez les brasseurs la comédie c'est
une histoire de famille on connaît
puisque votre fils alexandre brasseur
ça marche très très bien pour lui mais
j'espère me disant que ça va marcher on
peut se dire ça n'avance bien il était
dans maigret avec bruno cremer sur
france 2 hier
1 il écrit un court métrage qui raconte
la difficulté
de dire je t'aime à son père mais il dit
c'est pas du tout auto biographique
canton interview parce qu'il dit avec
mon père ça va très bien on s'appelle
pratiquement tous les jours exact on va
parler de votre vie vous êtes né en 1936
à neuilly vous êtes le fils de dettes
joyeux de pierre brasseur vous faites
partie d'une dynastie du théâtre qui
remontent à l'époque de la restauration
à 1820 10 820 alors le premier brasseur
c'était le créateur du théâtre des
nouveautés
après il ya eu jules directeur du
théâtre des variétés
son frère albert comédien vedette alors
votre prénom est le vrai nom de votre
père c'est pas brasseur c'est espinasse
oui et là on va parler de votre vrai
grand père qui était un personnage assez
assez extraordinaire dire que votre
grand mère a eu donc cet enfant avec
monsieur espinasse un qui était pierre
brasseur votre père alors c'était quoi
c'est un gigolo magnifique conte un très
beau mais était très beau et puis ils
demandent ma grand mère était comédienne
également mais celle l'énervé parce que
elle se prenait elle était une artiste
mais ça se voyait pas alors pour que
l'on sache que j'étais une artiste elle
avait remplacé son sac à main par une
boîte à violon oui pour moi comme ça on
va me prendre pour une artiste est là il
ya un très beau jeune homme qui l'a
qu'il a fait la course dans un autobus
et qu'il aime sur l'impériale de
l'autobus et quand votre père raconter
l'histoire jacques brel il l'a mis dans
le refrain de sa célèbre chanson
bruxelles c'est quand même
extraordinaire oui et il l'invité alors
il le donne et d'éthique elle est allée
loi ne le cherche encore parce que c'est
ni plus ni moins qu'un figurant
hallebardiers qui étaient eux dire que
en fait il était il était l'amant de
sarah bernhardt rien fait un théâtre il
avait fait croire à votre grand mère qui
est une grande vedette du théâtre
ce qui fait qu'il a dû excusez moi
l'expression n'a sauté dans la loge et
que votre père est né pierre brasseur
est né ainsi voilà mai mais un jour
quand mon père jouer qui ne le théâtre
sarah bernhardt il mais on est resté
avec le conserverons on a fait le tour
on est monté dans
les loges en eau et mme halimi je sors
certainement d'une de ces loges voilà
alors c'est espinasse est mort à 24 ans
d'une cirrhose du foie mais et votre
père tourisme
tu peux te faire comme vous a pris le
nom de jeune fille de sa grand mère
c'est à dire brasseur voiles exact voilà
votre merci odette joyeux évidemment qui
a été célèbre par entrée des artistes
par douce par le mariage de chiffon
enfin des films descendait les monuments
voilà et quand votre père la rencontre
d'être joyeux elle a 18 ans et sur le
tournage de grisou et et l'huile est
séduit par sa fraîcheur
il ose pas la toucher et le toucher
baisse de celui-là oui mais finalement
oui oui mais même après le mariage il a
considéré comme un enfant et elle dit
dans ses mémoires d'ailleurs c'est un
petit peu difficile avec pierre brasseur
et votre père sur le plan sur planche
charnelle elle dit nous vivions comme de
chasse aux orphelins ce qui vous a pas
empêché effectivement de naître un an
après le mariage malgré tout claude
brasseur voilà une enfance génial mais
vous avez côtoyé jouvet sarthe montand
signoret cocteau kessel viry qui était
votre parent oui bah c'est un peu comme
tous les enfants du monde c'est à dire
que l'on côtoie et on vit dans le milieu
de ses parents est souvent les les
enfants voient les collègues de bureau
bah oui effectivement les collègues de
bureau nous on perd des gens que vous
venez de citer
je suis toujours reconnaissant à mon
père de saad de ne jamais écarté alors
oui comme ça que sert qu'en fait vous
avez jamais eu à rentrer dans le métier
vous êtes né dans le métier quoi
contrairement à beaucoup de gens qu'on
reçoit qui ont eu du mal à rentrer dans
le système
vous vous étiez quoi oui il ya une
statistique officielle et internationale
que 70% des enfants reste dans le même
créneau professionnels pas la même
profondeur dans le même créneau
professionnelle de leurs parents oui ça
me paraît normal on est fâché les
médecins aujourd'hui chez les sportifs
bien sûr alors vous dites votre père m'a
toujours garder avec moi ils ont quand
même mis en pension
oui hein il est très malheureux en
pension moi je les sens mais maintenant
avec notre ami kersauson est moins un
peu et ses dunes
un détail une pub et si très désagréable
de n'ai pas honte de raconter je suis
d'une génération où j'étais adolescent
pendant l'occupation qui fait que je
j'avais peur parce que il fera des brefs
qui dit peur dit on dit que j'ai pissé
au lit très tard et au collège devait
avoir une dizaine d'années et à la
première récréation du matin on nous
faisait tourner autour de la cour de
récréation sous les rires des enfants
parce que les enfants ne sont pas
toujours tendre avec le drap accroché
autour du cou draps mouillés du pipi de
la nuit alors évidement les modèles
épisode et ghislain et puis un jour le
jour c'est vrai j'ai
et il y avait une branche par terre j'ai
attrapé la branche début j'ai commencé à
faire le clown faire le coup mais en
allant faisait d'artagnan je me sers 27
capes et je me suis rendu compte que les
enfants riaient mais il n'y est plus du
tout de la même façon c'est-à-dire
qu'avant irié contre nous et d'un seul
coup ils se sont mis à lire avec nous
c'est ça a été déjà que je vous êtes
révolter alors la punition était
supprimée dans l'est mais l'humiliation
dans votre esprit n'a pas été effacés
non c'était pas agréable à vivre un an
les études nous font chier mesure la
vérité un vrai manque carrément ya que
la récréation qui me met pas ce que l
arrestation de son fait et on fait
l'acteur ou les gendarmes
c'est ce que je continue alors pour
montrer à vous montrer comme photographe
à paris match il ya une anecdote
absolument extraordinaire un jour porter
en hollande avec walter 40 d'un grand
photographe et vous partez en hollande
les digues des polders avait cédé
inondant des 30 55 voilà et la hollande
était entièrement inondées et donc vous
arrivé là bas avec walter cajon donc
pour les photos pour match et il y avait
déjà une centaine de journalistes aaron
je leur idylle des balles passées
appareils puis il se serait calmée mais
pays me moquer son assistant attendait
ce qui me choque des termes d'aidé mais
trouve - cha 1 - ch alors bon je suis
parti à l'atelier de prouver un chat et
puis l'hymne amy tu vois la balle il ya
bien un arbre au milieu de cette immense
étendue d'eau il m'a dit fou mal chose
cela sur l'âme alors le foot et le ch a
circulé ne fait la photo puis on y re
partie de cette c était la photo la plus
vendue avoir fait le tour du bourg ge
symbole l inondation dolls des jeunes la
mise en scène l'histoire mais alors
voilà vous faites le photographe pour
match évidemment grâce aux relations
vous aviez de par votre service est
relativement facile de faire du people
oui et un jour vous allez voir elvire
popesco la grande peur popesco
pour match et elle vous dit pauvre con
tu ne dois pas faire ce métier de
journaliste je dois faire acteur oui
c'est d'ailleurs mon père qui m'avait
donné le curé meslier kouthia reportage
qui est intéressant à faire popesco
vient d'acheter le théâtre de paris
et elle va créer une pièce de marcel
pagnol effectivement elle m'a engagé
pour jouer trois rôles un frère de
julien charpentier
je vais tout de suite trois répliques
ensuite passé au cinéma vous jouez dans
le pays d'où je viens de carnets et
l'équipe de tournage bat s'installe dans
une caserne et là les officiers vous dit
bah tu dois faire son service militaire
pourquoi tu viens pas en algérie vous
partez en algérie un peu inconsciemment
faut bien le dire tant traitement et là
vous découvrez une autre réalité qui est
la réalité de la guerre et vous voyez
des soldats qui font des cartons sur
ceux qui bravent le couvre-feu
ce qui m'a le plus frappé c'est que si
de torture étaient en général exécutés
par des appelé les militaires doivent y
avait des gars y avait il y avait des
baroudeurs qui revenait d'indochine et
qui est terrifiant et eux non c'était il
ya même un malin plaisir chez chez les
appeler vêtu d'un uniforme d'un seul
cool 1-2 super par les années vérifier
annoncé ma balle non c'est la tienne
ah non c'est moi qui la fait tout
nous-mêmes que le brasseur un jour comme
ça vous trouvez en face
maintenant ce qu'on appelait les
fellaghas à l'époque et il va dégainer
et vous dégainez avant lui vous le tuez
d'exact toute votre vie vous regretterez
de ne pas avoir eu la culture politique
d'être un objecteur de conscience est
vrai c'est vrai parce que j'ai un
soutien au collège mon pote 18 les
oratoriens jouit effectivement
la télé la radio est formellement
interdit les journaux qu'on laissait
pénétrer à l'intérieur du traité
journaux sportifs et on avait
effectivement aucune aucune aucune
culture politique que j'ai vu en sortant
du collège blanc marc capitale
culturelle ont parlé pour dieu voilà
c'est ça vous ne l'aviez pas celui là
dans votre père quand vous avez la croix
de guerre est fou de rage parce que
évidemment ça correspondait pas du tout
à ses idées il vous en veut à ce
moment-là il m'en veut oui m'a envoyé
une lettre de dix ans de petit couronne
va pas porter ça n'oublie jamais que à
quelques secondes près une décoration
c'est une raison ou une autre vous
voulez beaucoup quand j'ai fait le paris
dakar
vous avez jamais écraser personne
ça fait un match de play off du musée
[Applaudissements]
soirée
ouais six fois le dakar quand même un
oui très sportif avoue on a besoin de
s'entretenir faut pas oublier que dans
notre métier nous sommes à la fois
instrumentistes mais on est aussi
l'instrument vous connaissez brasseur du
puy millions d'années ouais chez castel
ouais je vous ai fait la fête ensemble
olivier tous les deux là parce que c'est
un sacré fêtard brasseur il y toujours
pâle coliques mais ibra n'est pas du
tout la même chose
donc c'est pas là musée da c'est soit ça
c'est pas de moi êtes une définition de
prévert absolument vous avez fait la
fête ensemble
il est certain que au détour de
certaines nuits nous ne croisons oui et
est toujours de façon drôle vous êtes
bien fait sauter la tête beaucoup ma
main oui hein faut dire aussi une chose
c'est difficile d'aller au lit après le
théâtre c'est un peu comme si un mec
aller se coucher à sept heures du soir
en sortant du bureau mâchoire du mur à
minuit
alors claude le pire est à venir
maintenant c'est l'interview nul
on ne bouge pas pendant les trainings al
bien pouvait l'aider à olivier si vous
voyez qu'à un moment il a du mal en tant
que vieux copain de débauche vous pouvez
les voilà alors est-ce que vous
préfériez votre père ou votre mère à ses
interviews nul je vous ai prévenus je
préférais mes grands mères
ouais le mot le plus con en amour pour
vous c'est merci alors où
oui oui alors heureuse et pour vous
alors oui oui pour toi c'est quoi le mot
le plus con amant moi je parle pas
imaginez que vous croisiez un
extraterrestre le matin comme ça à
acheter des cigarettes
il vous dit t'es qui toi vous répondez
quoi et toi je tiens en vente dans un
sex shop vous seriez quoi en vente dans
un secteur maginez vous soyez quoi comme
objet d'un préservatif mais je vais vous
dire pourquoi parce que c'est exactement
la même chose que les metteurs en scène
les préservatifs
ça rassure quand on en main mais quand
il y en a pas qu'est ce que c'est bon
maintenant une question nul qui m'a été
envoyé par email parce que vous pouvez
m'envoyer des questions évidemment par
gym de béthune
savez vous pourquoi les abribus n'abrite
pas les bus je veux vivre à la question
si vous aviez un père heureux chez vous
voulu apprendre briller quelle phrase tu
à fermer le gaz tu as pensé la capote ou
coco arrête là coco je la prendrai as
tes acquis attributs riez vous le plus
de circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des jeunes où un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles il le
vieux qui stoppe dit rien ouais
alors vous préféreriez passé la nuit
avec anne sinclair lors sinclair ou
brett sinclair
ben je vais lire à 2/5 parce que je dois
à l'épaule et deux autres et ça lui soit
plaisir et vous carso
moi je vois ça je veux pas passer la
nuit toute façon non c'est moi j'ai
toujours vu ces choses là comme une
livraison mais ça veut dire qu'il ya une
heure d'arrivée une heure de départ
je vais vous les chiens une décembre
michel drucker que j'ai piqué oui pour
le compte de ce qu on dit généralement
vous allez bientôt le voir de coeur je
vais bientôt le voir
entraînez vous à vous la poser le
brasseur
a sion avec mon père au théâtre
l'enfant avec son agenda
non il à sardou il mis les moyens alors
maintenant mais je trouve ça très
courageux de sa part
1 ce qu'il aurait pu faire et joindre le
monde dont il est censé accueillir ces
noms il a acheté un théâtre c'est je
trouve ça plutôt sympathique et en plus
il fait défini novation pour la première
fois un théâtre privé va ouvrir ses
portes le mardi à 19h30 bat michel
sardou si tu nous regardes et si tu veux
venir tels bien fait et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu